[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález las imagenes
estremecieron a la región de américa
latina' un motín que tuvo lugar en el
centro de privación de libertad número
uno de guayaquil en ecuador dejó en 3
118 y 119 fallecidos y también cerca de
80 personas heridas todos ellos presos
en este centro reclusorio es considerado
hasta ahora el motín más sangriento en
la historia carcelaria de ecuador y dejó
en evidencia el terreno que han ganado
las bandas de las delincuencias el
narcotráfico la corrupción y también la
saturación del sistema
este episodio ocurrido en guayaquil nos
lleva a dar por supuesto una mirada y
analizar la realidad carcelaria en
américa latina'
estas son las cifras que les presentamos
a continuación para que ustedes
dimensionen más o menos cómo está la
ocupación el hacinamiento de las
cárceles en américa latina son unas
cifras aproximadas no la voy a leer
todas pero les leo por ejemplo el caso
de colombia en dónde está
en este momento está en uno de los
niveles más bajos pero está con 149
puntos 70% de ocupación de sus cárceles
del sigue venezuela con el 153 punto 90
por ciento sólo por leerles algunos por
ejemplo nicaragua 190 punto 90 por
ciento perú 232 punto 20 por ciento de
su capacidad este top lo encabezan el
salvador y haití el país centroamericano
reporta 333 punto 20 por ciento de la
ocupación y haití un país que conocemos
cuál es la crisis política sanitaria
social y de infraestructura en la que se
encuentra
450 y 4.40 por ciento y se me olvida
mencionar la crisis migratoria también a
la que está haciendo frente
esta realidad es escalofriante no deja
de ser triste obviamente lamentablemente
es un descuido de las autoridades
también en muchos aspectos son aspectos
comunes para los países de la región por
eso en esta edición del debate de france
24 cárceles latinoamericanas un sistema
inhumano para profundizar en este tema
saludamos a mario pazmiño él es
consultor internacional en defensa y
seguridad es coronel también retirado él
se une a esta conversación desde la
ciudad de quito la capital de guayaquil
también está con nosotros celso alvarado
abogado especializado en ciencias
penales y analista en temas de justicia
seguridad y derechos humanos él se
encuentra en la ciudad de tegucigalpa en
honduras y aquí en el estudio de france
24 me acompaña manfred group of ground
el auto asesor de seguridad nacional en
colombia
ustedes también nuestros televidentes
pueden participar en este debate con sus
comentarios y todas sus preguntas a
través de las redes sociales estamos en
facebook también en instagram en twitter
síganos como france24 guión bajo s de
sant y luego que es mi cuenta personal
les recuerdo que nuestra etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todos
sus comentarios sus preguntas sobre este
tema para que ustedes también sean
partícipes de él pues vamos a comenzar
abriendo la discusión acá en el estudio
de france 24 comienzo con manfred para
preguntarle sobre las causas de esta
crisis carcelaria que ecuador vuelve a
ponernos sobre la mesa después de este
motín que hubo en la ciudad de guayaquil
no es una cosa nueva en nuestra región
hemos visto motines en brasil también en
los recientes meses hemos visto también
en cárceles centroamericanas en mexico
pero esto vuelve a poner sobre la mesa
el tema de seguridad y la crisis en
general correcto
tomemos el tema de ecuador y luego hiló
después lo bajamos y lo ampliamos a una
generalidad de américa latina' ecuador
tiene una frontera con colombia y con el
municipio de tumaco y el departamento
del putumayo dos centros de acopio de
hoja de coca y de narcotráfico
y ecuador- hizo algo eficiente en su
gobierno que fue que desarrollan una
infraestructura de vial muy buena que
sucede que la presión de las fuerzas
militares de colombia y de la policía de
colombia ha cercado a los
narcotraficantes de tal forma que éstos
se han desplazado hacia el ecuador y el
ecuador terminó haciendo una especie de
outsourcing criminal a las bandas
grandes bandas criminales tanto de
colombia como de mexico y el tráfico las
trazas la forma como se mira las tasas
ilegales de barcos y aviones que salen
salen por esa por esa vía marítima rumbo
a méxico eso volvió al ecuador un centro
de tráfico diario gráfico importantísimo
pero no con la capacidad de la
criminalidad que hay en las bandas
criminales tanto de méxico como en
colombia entonces tuvo que absorber eso
que hace el gobierno ecuatoriano ante
eso sus autoridades militares y de
policía reaccionan y generalmente la
policía pues es más rápida en sus
reacciones en su doctrina y capturan
produce muchas capturas pero los
sistemas de justicia y los sistemas
criminales que son los que permiten la
resocialización de los delincuentes pues
son deficientes entonces la justicia
penalmente no puede procesar las
personas no imputa cargos y la gente
queda en un stand bay intramural mente y
empieza a la fuerza pública de lo que
tiene que hacer capturar y capturar y la
justicia no puede gestionarlo y después
viene el sistema criminal que es la
parte de resocializar la parte
estructura de las cárceles y esa parte
tampoco queda peor de rezagada y
terminamos en una crisis que no puede
ser absorbida entonces tenemos unas
fuerzas militares en general en américa
latina que son eficientes pero un
sistema de justicia ineficiente y un
sistema de red socialización criminal
también ineficiente y terminamos en
motines en el marginamiento si namientos
bien es un venezuela en colombia
colombia no se siente intervención
podemos hablar profundizar que pasó en
colombia porque a pesar de todo se lo
mostró
y eso hay que verlo y hay dos casos
exitosos para mirar también república
dominicana y costa rica que pasaron por
ese proceso y ya lo mejorar vamos a
hablar ahora con mario pazmiño en la
ciudad de quito el puede ampliar nos un
poco más sobre la situación allí en
ecuador que ha sido el caso como ya lo
decía yo que ha dejado otra vez en
evidencia esta crisis carcelaria para
abrir el debate y luego ya empezar a
profundizar en las diferentes aristas
que tiene este tema que son muchas señor
mario bienvenido al debate su opinión
sobre lo que ha sucedido ahí en ecuador
y que despertó todas las alarmas
muy buenas noches bueno primero yo creo
que el país está atravesando por una
improvisación permanente
gubernamental que tiene tres
potenciadores básicamente el primer
potenciador es la presencia de dos
carteles internacionales que están
operando desde algún tiempo atrás en
territorio ecuatoriano a través de mega
bandas este es el primer potenciador el
2º potenciador el desarrollo de mega
bandas delictivas que han comenzado a
operar a nivel del litoral ecuatoriano y
también dentro de los centros
carcelarios y el tercer elemento a mi
criterio es la corrupción una corrupción
campante que tiene y viene tomando gran
parte de la estructura del sistema
carcelario por otro lado hay una
penetración de las organizaciones del
crimen organizado transnacional sobre la
estructura gubernamental la estructura
de control y la estructura judicial a
esto es necesario también
irle sumando que por nuestro país
atraviesa dos grandes corredores esto
está ligado al narcotráfico y el crimen
organizado
recordemos que por territorio
ecuatoriano atraviesan los dos
corredores más importantes
que vienen desde colombia
el primero el corredor del pacífico que
viene desde el tapón de darién atraviesa
toda la costa colombiana y desemboca en
piura pasando por todo el litoral
ecuatoriano el es el corredor del
pacífico es el que genera la mayor
cantidad de droga y el otro el corredor
amazónico por el territorio ecuatoriano
pasa el 37.5 por ciento de toda la
producción de cocaína que tiene colombia
esto quiere decir aproximadamente unas
700 toneladas de las cuales las
autoridades exitosamente han logrado
capturar aproximadamente unas 120
toneladas no más de ello entonces ahí
existen básicamente el problema central
a mí a mi manera de pensar y eso es un
problema que está afectando directamente
el sistema integral de seguridad del
estado pasamos ahora a preguntarle a
celso en la ciudad de tegucigalpa en
honduras cómo está el panorama allí en
las cárceles centroamericanas en
honduras también un punto importante
para
el narcotráfico a través del triángulo
del norte es un salto
indispensable para poder llegar a los
mercados de méxico eeuu y canadá y
también con una serie de problemas
sociales que generan muchísima violencia
a celso buenas noches bienvenidos y su
opinión
buenas noches y bueno yo creo que las
dificultades que han expuesto quienes le
han perseguido es básicamente una
constante en américa latina el cual
honduras no escapa también verdad
tenemos un hacinamiento enorme al
interior de centros penales pero
también a la par existen algunos
factores estructurales
básicamente que el sistema penitenciario
a nivel latinoamericano es lo que
denominamos la cenicienta del sostén de
justicia es que saab el eslabón de todo
el proceso penal que ha sido
históricamente olvidado por otro lado
recuérdese que venimos de una cultura
de tradición jurídica española de
juicios escritos
canciones digamos
penales como única respuesta a la
delincuencia y la criminalidad y en
nuestro caso atribuimos precisamente al
uso desmedido de la prisión preventiva o
la detención como medida única verdad de
respuesta por parte del proceso penal o
sea en la criminalidad y en razón de eso
que eso genera un hacinamiento en
centros penales en el contexto
centroamericano
últimamente pues
si bien la criminalidad se ha aumentado
la medida única utilizada por los
gobiernos básicamente se limita a la
atención penal y la sanción penal que
habilitó precisamente la detención y eso
genera afinamiento y de porque la
ausencia de gobierno también a lo
interno de los centros penales hace que
en ocasiones sean los mismos internos
quienes tomen el control de los textos
penales y no el estado o la autoridad
militar o policial como debería
realmente hacer manfred aquí en el
estudio de france 24 vemos un poco ya
las piezas de este rompecabezas desde un
gran panorama de la situación vemos
varios factores la infraestructura del
hacinamiento un sistema judicial que ya
lo explicaba celso en detalle que
concentra a las personas prácticamente
en las prisiones y también el tema del
narcotráfico por donde pueden comenzar
los gobiernos a enfrentar estas
situaciones
infraestructura mejorar sus sistemas
judiciales mejorar su combate
con tráfico por lo menos en los casos de
colombia ecuador y perú que son países
productores y de tránsito santiago y yo
creo que no es una solución de un pedazo
es una solución que es integral y
articulada porque porque el caso
colombiano es interesante en este caso
colombiano tenemos unas fuerzas
militares y de policía muy eficientes en
ese combate pero la justicia que queda
desarticulada despegar entonces captura
y capturan o detienen la cantidad de
alijos de droga pero no se integra
porque procesalmente la justicia tiene
muchas debilidades en su formación ese
es el primer bloque y el segundo bloque
es el sistema criminal que se encarga
del sistema penitenciario la formación
de un guardia penitenciario no es la
mejor entonces porque eso requiere
resocializar a una persona que está en
proceso que fue un factor de podemos es
un ciudadano que toca garantizarlo y
reincorporado la sociedad y el vigilante
o el guardián no está no tiene esa
formación suficiente para hacerlo y
aparte es insuficiente para controlar
una cárcel de estas entonces le llega
una una una banda criminal de estas y
eso en colombia se vio era los
paramilitares contra las fuerzas de la
guerrilla tirándose granadas de patio a
patio yo pasaba en las cárceles
colombianas eso se vino controlando poco
a poco pero eso es decir es lo que
estamos viendo en ecuador en cuadro en
la situación aquí nunca debemos tener
medicación de 200 muertes en un año como
en ecuador porque obviamente la
capacidad no se puede dar entonces lo
primero que hay es integrar las tres
políticas que es donde está la debilidad
siempre la fuerza pública siempre será
más fuerte en cualquier país porque es
demostrar pero los políticos no quieren
en general meterse en la justicia
criminal porque eso no va réditos hacer
cárceles o mejorar el sistema o colocar
las normas mandela que son el enorme
técnico cree que una cárcel tenga
una celda tenga tantas medidas que sea
lo suficientemente apta para que un ser
humano sin red social y si no existe
entonces todo eso tiene que estar
armonizado por el político finalmente
por la fuerza pública se ve que la
cárcel no levanta votos en esencia
entonces eso el problema es articular
las tres cosas las tres políticas mario
en quito en ecuador ahora que ha salido
a la luz la situación carcelaria en ese
país suramericano llama mucho la
atención como han ganado terreno allí
las bandas delincuenciales y como usted
lo mencionaba dos de los grandes
cárteles del narcotráfico internacional
están haciendo presencia allí a través
de diferentes bandas están cediendo
terreno allí las autoridades y hago la
pregunta porque manfred dice que
las fuerzas militares o la policía o la
autoridad normalmente en estos países
pues son los que están dando la lucha
para combatir el crimen y que más o
menos están bien pero en ecuador están
perdiendo mucho terreno
yo creo que esa es una realidad yo he
dicho públicamente que el gobierno ha
cedido mucho espacio desde mucho tiempo
atrás no esté sino algunos gobiernos hay
una reducción presupuestaria
significativa con la asignación que
tenían para el manejo de los centros
carcelarios no hay una reinserción
social que es lo que dice la
constitución en su artículo 203 tampoco
hay por otro lado
un presupuesto adecuado sólo por poner
algunas estadísticas el 70% de la
población carcelaria que ya cumple su
condena y sale a la sociedad pues hay
una reincidencia de ese 70% ese ese 70%
regresa nuevamente allá porque no tiene
posibilidades afuera porque no tiene
posibilidades de afuera porque hay una
estigmatización social también eso es
necesario manejarlo y esto creo que es
una situación que se presenta en cada
uno de los países de américa latina la
persona que sale de la cárcel cumpliendo
su sentencia pues no es bien vista en la
colectividad y tampoco se le abren las
oportunidades laborales eso por un lado
por otro lado comparto
lo que había dicho entonces con relación
al tema que es necesario que los
gobiernos se preocupen más de estas
amenazas de estructurales y vayan
generando nuevas políticas públicas
políticas carcelarias que sean
verdaderamente soluciones a los
problemas que tienen cada uno de los
centros carcelarios esto creo que es
vital porque al momento lo que estamos
viendo es el camino en el caso
ecuatoriano el camino lo que está
haciendo es caminando rápidamente hacia
lo que es un país un estado fallido y
luego hacer la misma previa conjunta a
los 13 comienzos con celso en la ciudad
de tegucigalpa y si aquí hay un fracaso
si ya podemos hablar de un fracaso se ha
tocado fondo
esta política carcelaria en esta
política
legislativa para manejar este tipo de
situaciones
y hay un fracaso porque los gobiernos no
están funcionando y dando los resultados
sobre este tema como lo que ustedes
celso
sí correcto yo creo que en el caso del
sistema interamericano por ejemplo en lo
que va del presente siglo a venir
bastante hincapié mucho en el
afinamiento perdón en los centros
penales y lógicamente las situaciones de
asesinatos y muertes múltiples que se
han venido generando
ha hecho un llamado básicamente a los
estados
de posición de garante precisamente con
la población que el estado mismo somete
pues a la detención recuérdese de que el
privado de libertad se encuentra en una
situación de sujeción
frente a lo que el estado le ha impuesto
hoy en función de eso el estado en
ocasiones se olvida que el derecho a la
vida y la protección a la integridad
física es también un derecho que debe
ser parte del derecho que debe tutelar
cuando priva de libertad a una persona y
lo pone al interior del centro penal yo
creo que es un grave indicador el hecho
de que existan masacres y sobre todo a
manos de grupos organizados dentro de
los centros penales si van frente aquí
en el estudio de france 24
hemos hablado que este es un sistema
característico de la región de américa
latina cómo están si los sistemas en el
mundo anglosajón en europa buenas
prácticas que puedan adoptar en nuestra
región para mejorar los sistemas
carcelarios para mejorar las condiciones
de los presos de las personas que están
privadas de su libertad hay algún
ejemplo a seguir
digamos que en américa latina hay dos
ejemplos que es costa rica y república
la americana que pasan en esos dos
países ellos tienen una crisis pero lo
que hicieron fue formar al sistema
penitenciario y profesionalizar lo y
salarialmente
actualizarlo
y después fueron construyendo cárceles y
más penales de buena calidad con las
normas que se llaman mandela y eso
permitió darle darle salida un poco al
problema pero también a los numerosos
países esos países tienen crecimientos
económicos interesantes y eso alivia
también la situación social eso también
hay que o sea es decir no puede ser que
la pobreza es la que causa el crimen
pero algo algo a libia y claro por
supuesto que eso permitió ese aspecto
otros países que han tenido eso es
mejorar los sistemas de instrucción
penal eeuu por ejemplo tiene eso que es
sus jueces tienen muchísima mejor
formación para decidir quién va a la
cárcel quien no va a la cárcel quién va
con una fianza quien no va con una
fianza y a pesar de eso tienen problemas
pero por lo menos son mucho mejores para
no conquistar el sistema porque no
tenemos que meter a todo el mundo a la
cárcel es decir eso es eso es algo que
queda ahí pero es por la falta de
preparación en instrucción del sistema
judicial en los investigadores
judiciales esos son como ejemplos que se
pueden ver ahora hay un ejemplo que es
raro que es
el africano tiene congestión y no tiene
congestión penal pero su sistema de
defensa y de seguridad no es que sea la
mejor a seguir el día que tenga mejores
sistemas de seguridad defensa es posible
que pasen por el problema que pasa que
tenemos en américa latina entonces es
decir hay que matizarlo
y mirarlo en américa latina porque no
todos países están están en esta
situación hay unos que han venido
digamos en proceso de mejora como
colombia que vaya mejorando y otros que
han entrado un proceso de degradación el
caso de ecuador y el caso de honduras
que si es típico de un sistema colapsado
por las maras que existen en
centroamérica santiago también es el
mismo caso de el salvador un país vecino
en mayo en la ciudad de quito que tan
importante es en la cadena internacional
del narcotráfico el el eslabón que se
han convertido ahora las cárceles en el
caso de ecuador que tan importantes son
en esta cadena
de narcotráfico interna nominal son
básicamente vitales porque las
organizaciones de las bandas locales que
son las que se encargan de realizar la
protección de los centros de acopio y
las plataformas internacional de
distribución pues tienen están
tercerizadas por los cárteles mexicanos
sin considerar todavía la aproximación
de las dos protestas de las hileras que
están ya comenzando a desplazarse hacia
colombia y también entran en el área de
interés del territorio ecuatoriano
estas actividades del narcotráfico han
venido incrementando los niveles de
violencia y también los niveles de
penetración en el estamento
gubernamental eso nos lo grave las
campañas políticas están gran parte de
ellas financiadas con acciones del
crimen organizado transnacional entonces
tenemos una conjunción de problemas que
están ahí y que están afectando
directamente la seguridad integral del
estado yo creo que hay algunas
soluciones puntuales y yo me permitiría
manifestar lo siguiente primero en el
caso ecuatoriano creo
a corto plazo el estado tiene que ir
visualizando cómo mejorar el control y
creo que es importante puedes hacer una
reingeniería total del sistema una
reingeniería total del sistema que
comience con entregar el control
temporal a la policía nacional hasta
poder formar nuevos guías penitenciarios
y administradores de centros
penitenciarios administradores y guías
con perfiles internacionales y
protocolos nacionales de alta calidad y
selección por otro lado es necesario una
implementación tecnológica que permita
pues aislar estos pabellones en donde no
existe ningún tipo de control de las
autoridades quienes tienen las llaves de
acceso a los pabellones son los mismos
delincuentes de entonces es un problema
y una permanente vulneración de los
sistemas de seguridad hay que pensar
también a futuro en lo que es la
privatización carcelaria que dado buenos
resultados en algunos países y que creo
que en una
comunión de criterios y de apoyo entre
el estado y la empresa privada se puede
pensar en una acción de privatización
carcelaria a futuro bueno pues que hace
ideas sobre la mesa y le pregunto hace
el sol su opinión al respecto y se le
pregunto a manfred para terminar la
ronda su opinión sobre estas ideas que
deja acá para el debate mario sobre
posibles soluciones para esta crisis
carcelaria
sí yo creo también que otro elemento a
tomar en cuenta es la capacitación al
ministerio público está en la región
centroamericana por ejemplo
es tema criminalidad organizada de pista
de tiene una perspectiva aislada y no
desde una perspectiva
real que es realmente una situación de
delincuencia organizada y en ese sentido
que continúa persiguiendo por ejemplo al
narco al que hacer el narcomenudeo para
citar un ejemplo verdad y son
precisamente este tipo de delincuencia
la que en ocasiones satura los textos
penales y en esa visión casuística que
tiene los ministerios públicos es decir
que ven de manera aislada estos casos de
criminalidad organizada y se olvidan del
bosque que hay atrás verdad yo creo que
la reforma procesal a nivel
latinoamericano apuntaba precisamente a
que puede ser los delitos de mayor
impacto hablamos de corrupción
hablamos de narcotráfico de criminalidad
organizada hacia los cuales debería de
orientarse el accionar de los
ministerios públicos sin embargo en el
caso particular nuestra llevamos ya 20
años de haber impulsado esta reforma y
aún seguimos verdad
pero siguiendo lo que llamamos aquí
delitos de poca monta es decir quién
roba la cadena quién robó el celular
pero nos olvidamos de ir un poco más
allá y atacar con el accionar con la
raíz de la problemática que es la
corrupción justamente iba a preguntarle
a manfred la opinión que tenía en torno
a este tema y qué hacer con la
corrupción porque es a todo nivel
la propuesta que el señor coronel de el
ecuador es viable y es interesante
porque la privatización de cárceles si
ha funcionado en el mundo porque al
final lo que hacen lo que hacen una
cárcel lo que hace es atender un sistema
de personas 20 algunos servicios y que
entre esos en un enfoque que es que el
ciudadano infractor vuelva a
reincorporarse a la vida eso es más de
una autoridad de tipo civil que un golpe
que aunque un golpe de autoridad debe
haberle un cordón de seguridad por
supuesto pero ha funcionado bastante
bien para prestar servicios alimentación
salud porque todas estas cosas tienen
que estar aseguradas en un sistema de
salud todo eso todas esas detalles pues
están metidos ahí entonces ha sido
viable y es una buena solución
no es probarse como piloto es 12 tomando
el caso colombiano digamos con ecuador
creo que es la hora de que se activen
mejor los mecanismos binacionales
de lucha contra el crimen porque digamos
que ha sido se ha mejorado la relación
de que está el presente eduque con el
presidente la ha mejorado
pero creo que todavía falta aún más para
que se activen mecanismos realmente de
articulación entre las dos fuerzas de
militares para ese tema y persecución
penal y thiago porque es un tema que ya
ya toca en ese sitio y corrupción es un
tema es un tema muy profundo porque es
que la corrupción termina siendo
digamos el síntoma de una enfermedad
mucho más profunda uno le puede decir
acaso la hice en la frontera a un
funcionario judicial en tumaco que es un
municipio muy complicado decirle que no
sea corrupto pero es que no sea corrupto
cuando tiene una pistola en la cabeza
eso no es eso no es eso no es así y no
es tan sencillo entonces eso requiere
muchos más mecanismos para poder atacar
la corrupción la corrupción ataca por
primero darle seguridad a los
funcionarios que trabajan en esas zonas
en estos temas judiciales y ahí para
allá podemos entrar a un guardia un
guardia con un salario paupérrimo
enfrentado a una banda criminal que gana
cualquier cantidad dinero que volvió el
centro de poder la cárcel como lo
enfrentar y como decimos que no sean
corruptos y es que su vía está en riesgo
y su familia que puede ser ajusticiada
por una banda desde afuera entonces eso
es decir es un tema más grueso que
simplemente decir es que corrupción
tenemos que atacar más a fondo la cadena
para ir hacia la disrupción llegamos al
tramo final del programa y no puedo
dejar
de mencionar aquí el tema de los
derechos humanos los derechos para estas
personas que están privadas de la
libertad que también allí se presentan
muchos casos de violaciones hay
denuncias hay todo tipo de críticas todo
tipo de casos evidentes a través de los
medios de comunicación en toda américa
latina mar yo le hago la pregunta a
usted cómo garantizar los derechos para
estas personas que están allí que si
bien son delincuentes están pagando una
pena en un centro reclusorio tienen unos
derechos que tienen que ser garantizados
y en muchos casos no lo reciben
bueno básicamente la constitución de mi
país en el artículo 201 de la
constitución establece que el estado es
el responsable por la vida los derechos
y la reinserción social si el estado no
tiene la capacidad
para poder garantizar esos derechos de
los privados de libertad el estado puede
ser demandado al momento ya hay
investigaciones en curso por parte de la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos sobre esta masacre que existió
en días anteriores y en la cual pues
hubo violación permanente de los
derechos de las personas otra otra
situación similar es la falta de
atención gubernamental con la
reinserción social la falta de atención
de salud la falta de
recursos para que se mejoren las
condiciones de vida de esas personas de
allá yo creo que estos aspectos tienen
necesariamente que ser visualizados por
parte del gobierno de esta manera pues
para mejorar las condiciones de esas
personas
celso y los programas de reinserción
social como hacerlos efectivos como
hacerlos
y que logren sacar a estas personas de
esta de esta situación de criminalidad y
se les ofrezca un panorama una vida
decente
cuando yo creo que desde mediados del
siglo pasado la teoría de re han sido
precisamente parte de las respuestas no
obstante existen algunas contradicciones
con respecto al sistema penitenciario ya
cómo puede educar yo para la libertad en
un medio en el cual se me priva de la
libertad aquí en el caso hondureño por
ejemplo es este caso centremos la
familia siguiese el único contacto que
esta persona puede tener con el mundo
exterior
y prácticamente tiene que esperar mucho
tiempo para poder ver a su pariente y en
ese sentido en ocasiones surge el
cuestionamiento o sea ese contacto con
el exterior o ese aislamiento que somete
el mismo estado a estas personas también
y que ayuda al proceso de
resocialización y de reeducación yo
prácticamente considero que hay formas
alternas de reeducar a una persona de
reinsertarlo y creo que debemos apuntar
precisamente hacia un sistema en el cual
la libertad puede hacer la regla y su
privación la excepción vino tal cual
estamos ahorita en la privación de
libertades la rabia y la atención con
esta teoría de medidas que permitirían
un mejor proceso de relocalización
importante esa reflexión se hizo desde
tegucigalpa
opiniones por acá manfred yo creo y yo
comparto lo que acaba de decir el por
qué es cierto o sea es decir metemos una
persona a la cárcel queda en stand by
esperando si fue inocente si no fue y no
que es indeterminado y finalmente
terminar puedes pasar 5 6 7 8 años
y eso acumula el sistema a común el
sistema con la gravedad que tiene el
sistema de salud adentro no se ha
colapsado la alimentación precaria la de
la celda de mala calidad enfermedades
pululan amenazas dentro de las mismas
cáceres porque bandas internas dominan
los dos penales entonces toda esa
situación implica dos primero hacer un
diagnóstico realmente muy profundo de
las cárceles eso se hizo en colombia
diciendo está la línea base y a partir
de esto las cárceles deben que ser
construidas con esos sistemas de esta
manera y tienen que ampliar el sistema
el sistema de infraestructura debe ser
ampliado no hay otra pero antes de eso
la cadena antes de eso en la justicia si
la justicia no mejoramos los
procedimientos judiciales para que los
investigadores judiciales no cometan
errores y le entreguen a los jueces ya
los fiscales le entregan la información
correcta para que rápidamente
despachemos a las personas a lo que sea
o no impulsamos cargos o lo liberamos y
no lo dejamos ahí el problema lo vamos
hasta internet no vamos a ir siguiendo a
profundidad es decir el procesamiento de
los de bueno vuelven por buen
procedimiento penal
buena buen sistema carcelario me queda
un minuto de programa mario las
conclusiones 20 segundos para usted que
va a seguir de aquí en adelante que
panorama nos vamos a enfrentar más
crisis o vamos a empezar a ver algo de
cambio
yo creo que el país va a estar
yo diría con una situación de crisis
permanente en el sistema carcelario
estimo yo que de aquí a un mes a más
tardar tendremos una nueva crisis porque
el estado como tal no está adoptando las
medidas que tendría que hacer para poder
corregir los problemas naturales es la
tercera crisis que tiene ecuador este
año se alzó rápidamente a 20 segundos su
conclusión
y bueno yo creo que hay que aplicar el
principio de humanidad en las penas y
dignificar un poco también la estadía de
quienes pasan por este tema
penitenciario verdad la pena como tal no
debe ser una desviación o el pago de un
pecado sino básicamente debe llevar
implícita un objetivo y éste puede
socializar y devolver a cualquiera de
los ciudadanos manfred aquí en el
estudio rápidamente para dar con
articulación de las tres políticas
las fuerzas armadas que la seguridad la
el sistema de justicia y la de criminal
articuladas y tengan usted las opiniones
de nuestros invitados varios celso y
manfred gracias por haber estado con
nosotros aquí en el debate ustedes
pueden seguir opinando a través de las
redes sociales sigan con nuestra
programación
[Música]